[Music]
getting breaking news out of Gaza
several Rockets have been fired from the
besieged Palestinian Enclave towards
Israel there are warning sirens being
sounded in and around Gaza as well as
Central and Southern Israel Let's cross
now to Y elide who's joining us on the
phone line from Gaza so y just tell us
more about what you're hearing and
what's
happening uh yes Nick it all started
just short minutes ago or just a while
ago I'm talking about barrages of
rockets being launched at the same time
from different areas in the skies of the
Gaza Strip towards the Israeli town uh
uh really the intensity of the rockets
that were fired from Gaza was never seen
such an amount of rockets at the same
time uh the Rockets are still being
launched until this moment uh in the
southern part of Gaza Strip in unit and
in the central part in D bah also uh we
we we've seen uh we've heard local
Witnesses say that uh resistance
factions have crossed on the other side
of the Border according to local
Witnesses so which means that
Palestinian uh military uh uh or armed
men from the Palestinian military groups
have crossed onto the other side of the
border and there was um an armed an
armed actually uh confrontation with the
Israeli troops on the other side of the
Israeli Gaza Border in the central part
and in the southern part of the Gaza
until this moment there is no one
statement to explain to us what is
actually happening is this an action or
a reaction there is no statement
clarifying the situation all we can see
and here is uh barries of rockets uh
being launched from the goet strip and
dozens of rockets uh from the Iron Dome
uh flying to intercept these
rockets and you just give us the context
of this remind us of the most recent uh
bares of this kind coming out of
Gaza right now while I'm talking to you
I can see them right here above my head
more bares more Rockets are being uh um
fired uh according also uh to Israel uh
spokesman military spokesman they said
that the range of these Rockets some of
them have reached until uh Tel aiv and
also to the Western uh Jerusalem so um
we can see that the rockets that are
being fired are not just a um uh short
range Rockets but also high range
Rockets
and now this is something really uh
that's uh not normal it's extraordinary
because also in uh previous escalations
these kinds of rockets were not used
until it was really getting complicated
between the Israeli side and the group
that is being um in in fighting with the
Israeli side so for these kinds of
rockets to be used from now uh a day one
from the first incident we're still very
much uh concerned about what has
happened we can't still understand what
has happened since there is no
clarification from any uh any of the
sides
yet uh y tell us about the current state
of tensions uh as far as and Israel are
concerned I'm sorry again again next
could you tell us about the current
state of tensions at the
moment yes true there there has been it
has been a very long uh period of time
of ongoing tensions uh especially
because of the uh Jewish uh uh holidays
that have been taken place in in in
September and and in the beginning of
October and it was it was a a really a
long uh period of tension and uh a lot
of provocations by the Israeli settlers
and and National Orthodox that were
storming ala comp
uh the Violence by the Israeli forces
towards the worshippers in Jerusalem and
in Ina compound these uh provocate these
were uh provocative actions towards the
Palestinian uh factions or fighting
groups here Gaza they have stated many
times that this will lead to an
explosion this will lead to a further
escalation border uh um border uh
confrontations have taken place border
protests have taken place from through
the Gaza Israeli border all those uh
past weeks also to Pro to protest these
proa acts uh uh until yesterday it was
the launching of Al Jihad or Islam Jihad
group the 36th uh anniversary of the
launching of the group and they were h a
lot of messages by other factions that
had uh came to give their blessings to
this um ceremony and the the the the
neutral actually uh to this of the
functions was that they send a message
to say that they're watching closely
what is happening and they are telling
the Israeli occupation not to go further
with these provocative Acts that may
lead to an explosion in the region y
we'll leave it there for the time being
thanks very much indeed for that yide
they're reporting on the barage of
rockets being fired uh out of Gaza never
seen such an amount of rockets she said
at the same time and they're still being
launched as we speak let's talk to Sarah
harit who joins us on the phone line
from the occupied East Jerusalem Sarah
what are you hearing from your
end um that's right well there's been
obviously an ESC
here and things have been very tense
this year between um Israel and
Palestinians you've had the largest
number of deaths um two more than 250
Palestinians killed in occupied
territories um things had escalated in
occupied West Bank in the last few days
in haa um where there had been
provocations that's been going on uh for
for months uh between Palestinians and
as well as uh illegal um Jewish settlers
um so you know the situation here has
also been extremely tense even here in
occupied East Jerusalem in the last uh
few days it's been the uh Jewish holiday
of sukot one of the biggest uh
holidays held here in by in Israel by
the Jews um where we've seen um Jewish
um pilgrims walking through the old city
um some of them trying to um some of
them spitting on on even uh Christian
worshippers as they walk past some of
those Christian worshippers were
tourists um so there's even been an
escalation there the situation has been
very tense and this comes as no surprise
even uh overnight um the uh uh
Palestinian authorities had entered um
uh one of the areas in um uh in occupied
West Bank to try and stop armed groups
there then arise in armed groups amongst
Palestinians especially in in refugee
camps as we're seeing this current
Israeli government which is uh has been
very tough especially on occupied areas
you have um a very
Hardline uh members within the
government that are uh uh um Ultra
Orthodox they very much believe in the
expansion of um settlements and legal
settlements in occupied territories
building of new homes 5,000 home units
that they want to approve for soon so
you're seeing this year it's one of the
tensest years that there has been in
more than a
decade and Sarah as we speak Rockets
still being fired next is the question
of the Israeli
response um so far we haven't seen one
at the moment um but we'll obviously
keep monitoring that they usually will
respond and this current government
Benjamin Netanyahu who's come back in to
power through a coalition government um
you know he's he's he's been um very
much uh you know um pushing for um to to
quash any uh Rockets coming in and and
um you know there has been a response
obviously things escalated a few months
in Gaza as well so we'll just have to
wait and see what happens there all
right sorah thanks very much Le for that
update back with you as things progress
there so just a quick recap bares of
rockets being fired uh from Gaza
reaching as far as uh Tel Aviv and West
Jerusalem never seen such an amount of
rockets at the same time reports our
correspondent y side more on this as we
get it here at Alero